l'avenir des enfants de la République
reste encore par trop déterminé par le
nom de famille l'endroit où l'on est né
le milieu auquel on appartient c'est la
pire des injustices l'inégalité de
départ la promesse républicaine c'est
celle de l'égalité des chances et au
fond je veux qu'on mette fin à cette
France du ceci n'est pas pour moi ou
ceci n'est pas pour toi de ces enfants
qui continuent à se dire que parce
qu'ils viennent de tel de ce quartier
qu'ils ont ce nom l'accès à telle
formation ou tel diplôme l'accès à la
culture de pas du n'est pas un droit
pour eux ça existe c'est une réalité et
aussi longtemps que ça existe ça vient
éroder l'adhésion à la promesse
républicaine et tout ce que je viens de
vous dire sur l'ordre ne sera pas
possible tout ce que je viens de vous
dire sur la force sera aussi affaibli
vous retrouverez une forme d'en même
temps qui est familier mais qui n'est
pas une faiblesse qui est une double
radicalité qui n'est pas une ambiguïté
qui est une double ambition car et c'est
vrai depuis le début de notre 3e
république l'ordre va avec le progrès
l'autorité va avec avec l'émancipation
indissociable et donc oui la réponse à
ça c'est l'école l'école l'école là
aussi continuer le travail commencé avec
encore plus de
force auprès des enfants les plus en
difficulté systématiser les devoirs
faits au collège en particulier dans les
endroits les plus en difficulté c'est
indispensable travailler sur les
vacances et le temps scolaire Premier
ministre naguerre ministre de
l'éducation nationale avait commencé ce
travail pour décaler les examens parce
que les vacances longues sont un élément
d'injustice soci et commencer aussi dès
la 5e l'accompagnement à
l'orientation qui est un élément
absolument décisif d'une plus grande
égalité et c'est tout ce que nous allons
conduire au collège au lycée et au
premier cycle universitaire avec les
ministres qui sont maintenant en charge
de ces sujets c'est aussi ce travail que
je veux continuer par un meilleur accès
à la culture et qui sera au cœur du
mandat de la ministre faire en sorte que
d'où qu' viennent des quartiers
populaires urbains à notre ruralité on
puisse avoir accès à la
culture